even just go into like uh what is it
called optician
yeah yeah it went here and it was such a
streamlined quick experience yeah in the
UK is [ __ ] awful oh yeah oh really
yeah yeah everything to do with
Healthcare in the UK is just takes it
was forever yeah I don't know I thought
it would have been the opposite I don't
know I don't know it was like want to
spoke English really well no they it's
pretty bad I found a dentist here that's
like fluent English they do everything
like an American Wood and it was great
it was better than I ever had in the UK
yeah yeah they were like we're gonna
remove everything and redo to your teeth
we're gonna fix it all right I had like
a filling from the UK right
and they used Mercury and Mercury for my
filling so it's like a black filling and
people what it was a really old style of
filling just trying to like mercury
poison you well you know the UK is very
up to date with dental practice no it
was it was like an old thing they used
to do for some reason I guess in Wales
kept doing it they just did when I was a
kid it's like the thing in Dune where it
like crunches down and explodes
it genuinely felt like when I found out
that because I didn't know it was
Mercury this entire time I was just like
I had a filling and then the the dentist
was like yeah you got a Mercury a
Mercury feeling what and she's like you
want me to like just take it out and
I'll just put one in right now that's
good and I was like oh yeah it was like
done in like 20 minutes it's awesome
what the [ __ ] in the UK have to make a
booking come back in seven months yeah
and then they'd be like oh we canceled
your booking because you didn't reply to
our email two days ago they went in spam
dang thing Japan it's true yeah I think
there's a little bit of Truth
is there anything that you thought was
going to be good that was [ __ ] uh
uh was it all been uh [ __ ] [ __ ] um not
to your expectation I guess like a lot
where you were saying about people
comments in in the beginning a lot of
people are kind of like oh yeah did you
know this and that and so I was kind of
like tensed up when I was going to be in
those situations like people say old
people are really racist and whatever
I'm not sure yeah it's like yeah it's
like any country every old every country
is racist old people yeah exactly yeah
yeah so yeah one meeting in like all the
neighbors we were just like oh God are
they gonna hate us they're just gonna
yell at us but yeah and then they were
lovely and you feel like [ __ ] free yeah
I guess so yeah I mean I actually had to
make a conscious choice to like just let
my own experience dictate what yeah he's
gonna be here because yeah there is so
many people saying stuff about
everything I mean when I always tried to
say hi to my elderly uh I mean yeah
they were not they were not no they were
definitely yeah
well that's probably because of you
that's funny they show me they're like
damn I thought it was Felix are you
PewDiePie
so I got him back I got them back I put
vegetable oil at their their front door
that's how you do it okay
no just don't get just don't take your
garbage out on the wrong day that's it
that's it like if you want a speed run
getting hated by your neighbors it's
it's garbage out on the wrong direction
I know that and I've been terrified of
that and I've been so careful every time
like checking my garbage and I this is
like a huge relief every time I see
they've taken it yeah no I I got the
exact same thing and then one time I
didn't they didn't take it yeah and I
was going to the supermarket and I
walked past and I saw a bin had a bag
hadn't been taken and I was like I hope
it's not mine it's not mine it's not
mine I walk to supermarket and I'm like
I should just go check it out
and it was [ __ ] mine
they did like a thing on it like a
plastic wrapper being like we did not
take this because it was not sorted
correctly and I was like no
[Music]
sometimes I see other people do it wrong
and they leave it I'm like they're gonna
think it's me yeah
every time I put the garbage out when I
see the garbage uh that has been sorted
incorrectly I'm like I know they're
gonna blame it on me because I'm the
only
people have a conspiracy this is why
living in like an apartment complex is
so op now like everything you take the
trash out whenever you want you can take
it to the area
oh it's great I used to have to like
make a giant Palace of cardboard and
take it out on the cardboard yeah yeah
yeah
but then they installed a security
camera in the cardboard place and I'm
like is it because of me did I do
something probably yeah
they're looking out for me although they
have a big sign saying security camera
oh wow in English
yeah oh no yeah they started putting out
signs at my place too and it hasn't been
signs for like two years
I wonder why they're starting to put out
instructions
[Applause]
man was it okay I don't know if this is
too personal to ask was it weird going
back to the house after you know
obviously got they got like robbed ages
no it wasn't weird no no I guess I was a
little paranoid people were gonna break
in again
but uh no no it wasn't weird plus they
didn't take anyone on my stuff too so
sorry
you're like damn this is [ __ ] easy
did they like really ever try and make
like an effort or was it just kind of
like yeah it sucks to suck man that's
just one of those crimes that doesn't
usually yeah yeah they give us tea at
the station that's great
that's all I needed
did it wait actually it happened when
you're out completely outside of Japan
right you couldn't come in
yeah I think two three years ago I think
it was before covet actually yeah we're
able to come back in okay okay oh sorry
I thought you hadn't come back and I was
like that must be weird yeah you
confused me too now I was like wait I
don't know
uh yeah yeah we got that sorted but no
we didn't get anything back yeah of
course yeah are you gonna try and learn
Japanese when you're here I'm trying but
it's no
get ready get ready for the comments for
in like three years where they're like
yeah what do you mean you're not fluent
yeah and it's like ah if only that's how
it works three years more like three
months I I remember feely's tasted me
the other day being like what are you
doing and I'm like not much what about
you and he's like I'm learning kanji and
I want to die
yeah it's pretty bad I was just like yep
sounds about right Japanese is
definitely one of those things for that
the first the more you study the more
you realize how [ __ ] you are at it yeah
yeah how much more of a challenge it is
yeah because it's like that perfect I
don't know what the curve is called
right but yeah like just the learning
curve learning curve well like it's like
confidence versus knowledge and it's
like you learn cat's gonna hear a gun
yeah you're like [ __ ] yeah
three alphabets alphabet's done
very satisfying when you finally like
have a conversation that doesn't go at
all badly you're like wow I said
everything correctly and I understood
everything this is great I'm fluent and
then someone says something else later
you're like I hate my life anything I
remember Aki was saying like the number
one thing that made her like really
happy was when she walked outside and
then the one sign she couldn't read
suddenly it was just like I know what
that means now yeah it's cool I've seen
that before yeah
yeah I remember when you guys a couple
of years ago you were talking about like
Jewel zoo and like how you get it all
the time you especially told me like
don't worry you'll get it all the time
for links yeah and then I come here and
I practice a lot and I'm like
where's my [ __ ] joke
you haven't got it yet no but you took
like a couple weeks and then I was
chatting with my neighbor and then all
of a sudden she's like oh yeah I feel
like I was just like I feel like I feel
like sometimes they Josue you and
they're like I don't know what else you
want me to say yeah [ __ ] you Japanese is
good by the way by the way yeah I I've
noticed it's much harder to get Jose in
Tokyo but as soon as like do you travel
outside of Tokyo like maybe stay in a
like ryokan or something like I
literally I came back just from hakadate
and I got Joseph more in hakadate than
my entire year in Tokyo oh yeah because
everyone's just like what what you can
speak just a little bit of Japanese with
I think it's Tokyo and like he's a
foreigner he's probably he could
probably say like a few words you know
and it's not even like something that
impressive either you could just like go
up to a store and be like konnichiwa and
they'd be like I'm going to Joseph I'm
just saying thanks
another one I'm counting them damn I'm
sorry I'm sorry I lied to you because
you haven't added a lot no no no I'm not
happens all the time
it'll come Felix okay okay thank you I'm
still waiting but like do you guys say
to people that speak good English then
yeah I do yeah yeah yeah
I say it ironically but I don't think
they take it ironically yeah yeah we
feel like very good English then the
Japanese person will be like oh thank
you sometimes some people are like yeah
I don't speak any English and then they
stop talking and they speak pretty good
English and you're like bro what the
[ __ ] your English is like good you could
live how humble Japanese people I know
it just annoys me yeah like I feel like
I've met more good speaking English like
good Japanese speaking
than I have like foreigners that can
speak good Japanese oh yeah especially a
lot of Japanese people who do speak
English or are you know trying to learn
a very uh very eager to speak it so they
come up to you and they start speaking
they're normally really nice that's
pretty cool because I think it's also
the whole thing of like you know
Japanese people they they don't know how
to be like cocky or like overconfident
with their skills so the only thing they
can do is undersell themselves even
though they might be like [ __ ]
amazing at it but that just annoys the
other person even more it is a bit
annoying
it's like you're not it's like it's like
oh I'm not very good I'll just saying
confidently wrong in Japanese
but like I do notice when because they
want us to practice their English uh
they always try to speak English to you
but I want to practice my Japanese so I
had this like awkward taxi ride the
other day I I had this awkward taxi ride
the other day where you know we go in
and the taxi driver tries his best to
answer us uh ask us stuff in English so
I got an entity driver he asks oh oh
where do you want to go and I'm like I
answer in Japanese I'm like here's my
address
and can I take the highway please and
then it's like a battle because even
though I was speaking Japanese he would
reply to me in English I would enter and
reply in Japanese so he asks uh like he
asks uh temperature uh oh okay and I I
would like reply yes the temperature is
fine it's the most like no you bad yeah
I'm like please speak Japanese to me I'm
trying to price my Japanese like no
you're both doing it though yeah yeah
he's like who's gonna fold first
it's like I will not fall I will fight
yeah I love it but yeah like it's uh
it's you know one of the best places to
get practice for your Japanese honestly
like taxi drivers and just going out
going out to bars
that's like one of the best places to
get the confidence tune yeah because you
drink and you're like oh I'm gonna make
so many mistakes but then everyone else
is really chill yeah everyone loosens up
a bit it's really good yeah yeah when
you're drunk just like your
embarrassment levels just go down so
you're just like not afraid to make
mistakes yeah you learn way more than
yeah yeah you hesitate way too much oh
yeah I say this again have you been in
have you been enjoying the nightlife
much in Japan uh nightlife no because my
dog is demented so we can't do anything
at night usually oh no but yeah she gets
crazy at night basically